in this portion of our world views and
values class we're now going to turn to
one of the major works by an 18th
century philosopher Mary Wollstonecraft
it's written around the turn of the 18th
to the 19th century so it's it's
occupying a very important place it's
also considered to be one of the major
you might say even founding works in in
feminist thought but it goes beyond that
as analyses of some some great
intellectual power that have to do with
their understanding of virtue or
understanding of society of the
relations between men and women as usual
with this class what we're going to do
in this first part is talk about the
literary genre of this work we'll talk
about the historical context which is
quite important and then we'll talk
about some of the key themes this video
is intended primarily just to help you
get ready to move into the work so what
do we want to keep in mind with respect
to the literary genre of this work as
we're first approaching it so it's
called a vindication and when you see
that term vindication
you should think polemics or controversy
there's already some topics in play that
people have staked out a position on and
in order for there to be a vindication
there has to be somebody you know
presenting some resistance and so this
is actually the second of
Wollstonecraft's vindications she wrote
an earlier one in 1790 called the
vindication of the rights of man this
one is the 1792 work called the
vindication of the rights of women
there's a kind of parallelism there but
the the later work is considered to be
much more important and it's much more
general and it's it's a purview you can
say now what would the vindication
actually be about what's the context in
which it's written if you look at the
dedication
she dedicates it to this this guy
Talleyrand and Talleyrand had written a
report to the French National Assembly
and in his report he was talking about
education in general and he had a part
in there where he's saying women should
only get a domestic education men should
have a public education women should
have an education and provided at home
that's what a domestic education means
so Wollstonecraft is is actually
responding to this report by writing
something to say no no you've got it all
wrong here's why the position that
you're taking is actually wrongheaded
and misguided
she's broadening the topics away from
just that one particular report to the
issue of women's place in society in
general and the progress of humankind
what that's going to take so what she's
going to do as she's writing this is
give you an a set of essays each chapter
is its own you might say self-contained
essay and she's coming back to the same
basic ideas looking at them from
multiple perspectives so you know
there's a little bit of repetition
involved there but she's actually such a
good stylist that you probably don't
notice too much of that she's great at
blending several different styles
together you're gonna notice also that
she's engaging several other authors
very often by mean some of them are not
quite so important like this dr. Gregory
one of them is of particular importance
that is jean-jacques Rousseau who had
been very influential on the French
thought that that's you know going on at
the time of the French Revolution
so she's addressing Rousseau very
directly in this and unless you know a
lot about Rousseau's philosophy or at
least some of the broad outlines some of
the things that he's saying might not
make complete sense until you get those
those puzzle pieces so when you're
reading this work what you want to be
doing is looking
for the argument that's being developed
she's doing it though in multiple ways
so you have to do a bit of
reconstruction and she's moving from
topic to topic to topic because they're
all interrelated with each other if you
had to say that there's one central
single point around which the entire
vindication is constellated or moves
around or is you know arranged it would
probably be that unless women are
afforded a sort of equality of treatment
in education that will allow them to
develop virtues to develop their minds
to become independent we will never have
a good Society let's talk now about the
historical context of this work it's a
very exciting story that we've got to
tell not only about the big picture the
panorama of what's going on in Europe at
the time but also about the life of this
this this woman mary wollstonecraft as a
writer as sort of a representative of
the very education and focus on virtue
that she's writing about in her work so
the historical context if you wanted to
really boil it down to a kind of slogan
you could say that she's writing at a
time when the age of enlightenment is
turning into the age of revolution what
do we mean by that so the age of
enlightenment was the 18th century and
insofar as the 18th century was about
the development of sort of public
opinion and power structures social
structures outside of the clergy outside
of the nobility the rise of the
bourgeoisie to gain more and more and
more authority power not only
politically but but socially
intellectually the criticism of existing
institutions as being unreasonable as
being arbitrary as breeding and
perpetuating superstition and
exploitation of human being might
being that was what the enlightenment
was was about and part of the promise of
the Enlightenment was if we could just
like sweep away all this this old stuff
all this d'etre tests then we could have
a rational society in which people don't
have to exploit each other in which
everybody can develop the way that they
ought to be in which human nature would
truly be realized instead of being
stunted and held back now why does it
shift into an age of revolution because
people who have power don't like to let
go of that power and people who want to
see major changes take place sometimes
have to push and radicalize their their
efforts so that they overthrow the
present state of society and begin again
and that's what a revolution really is
it's a drastic change where you move
from this position to that position it
goes beyond just reforming changing
little bits and pieces you're saying we
got to start all over again and that's
indeed what they were doing the French
Revolution was more radical than the
American Revolution and the American
Revolution was pretty radical throwing
off the British King starting a republic
having a constitution you know having a
declaration of independence all these
sorts of things had their fruit in the
French Revolution which comes after that
and in the French Revolution they kill
the king they kill a lot of nobility
they you know nationalize a lot of
institutions that were in the hands of
the nobles or the church it becomes very
very dramatic what's what's going on and
there's a lot of debate as there always
is when there's a revolution about well
where should we go from here what kind
of new society are we trying to build
now along with that goes a discussion
about the rectification of inequalities
how should we change the new social
system apart from the old so that we can
create new opportunities so that we can
equalize things so that we can get rid
of these hereditary class distinctions
or you know distribute wealth more
fairly or you know make it possible for
people who are excluded from certain
institutions to get into them and
whenever you do that you end up opening
the door to somebody who you weren't
planning on saying something also
raising their hand and saying what about
us
and Wollstonecraft is not the only woman
at the time to do that as a matter of
fact there's plenty of other women who
are saying you're right this this you
know human rights the the rights of
human you know of man to to property to
happiness that's great how about for us
too
can we have some of this great new
revolutionary society and that tended to
make quite a few of the men who were the
ones who were actually you know doing
the the the political work in the
revolution the ones who are voting in
the National Assembly the ones who are
making the speeches let's go to make a
lot of them very uncomfortable because
they were used to having something that
they could rely upon a you might say
permanent underclass of women and
somebody like you know jean-jacques
Rousseau had had even though he was for
the rights of man and the rights of
humanity and the abstract he actually
said that women basically exists to to
make men happy and they should be
educated for that purpose so there's a
lot going on here a lot of Furman's so
there's also you can say there's i've
already talked about the fact that the
public sphere has become very important
by now so we're thinking about books or
the articles we're thinking about essays
we're thinking about pamphlets even as
ways in which people are not just
spreading information but appeal
to the the educated class which now
includes quite a lot of the people who
are making decisions appealing to them
and saying this is the way that we
should think about things and those
other guys over there they're dead wrong
Wollstonecraft is is waiting right into
this she has met some of the other
movers and shakers of that time like
Edmund Burke like Thomas Paine the
people who are writing these these
popular tracts that are trying to make a
case about how society ought to be
ordered what human life ought to be like
and there's there's a lot of things
going on the Republic of Letters has now
become something a little bit less
genteel and a little bit more like a
debating floor so she is taking part in
that this is probably a good place to
talk about her biography a little bit so
Mary Wollstonecraft in many respects
exemplifies the kind of influence of
education that she is advocating for men
and for women she also exemplifies to a
certain extent the orientation towards
marriage towards love towards virtue
that she is holding to be to be central
she's also exemplifying certain what we
might call bourgeois attitudes or values
and I'll come back to that in a moment
so she lives a rather unconventional
life in in many respects some of this
only comes to light later on when her
widower William Godwin publishes a work
after her death called memoirs of the
author of a vindication memoirs of the
the author of a vindication of the
rights of women where he sort of reveals
everything that actually ends up doing
some harm to her reputation once it
comes out and and prevents some people
from from reading her for a while but
she is in many respects a self-educated
person she learns through reading
voraciously whatever she's able to come
across she ends up deciding at a time
when very few people could make it as
authors and almost no women had tried to
do this she decides that she's going to
make a living as an author after trying
a number of other different occupations
that were a bit more traditional being a
lady companion being a governess she
decides no I'm gonna I'm gonna become an
author and she learns more and more and
more by doing so when she's talking
about the importance of our professions
in our continuing education
she's an exempt she's an example of that
because she you know was able to just
sort of suck in literature from every
corner of the globe she translated
articles from French and German articles
and books so you know she was really at
the heart of what was going on
intellectually in that century and she
did so through hard work through
cultivating virtue through you know
pressing ahead through not being the
sort of you know Wallflower who shrinks
back but being somebody who was quite
assertive as a matter of fact William
Godwin she kind of turned him off at
first when she fed him there's this
great story that's told about her where
the the very first night that they met
you know William Godwin was kind of a
rebel type and pretty radical himself
and so he's meeting this this very
intelligent you know vivacious woman and
what does she do she argues with him all
night long the entire night but that was
that was the kind of person that she was
and it fits her mentality because she
thought that that's the sort of a thing
that you would actually have to do in
art it's a merit equal respect you'd
have to show the
you have a mind you have to show that
you can cultivate male virtues that
they're not really male virtues at all
that they're just virtues and that they
belong to to everybody she does Express
a rather bourgeois point of view which
makes perfect sense for the for the time
because she is part of that that social
class you can say that you know it's
it's essentially a middle class way of
looking at things where the the rich
even though they have a better social
position they really are not morally
better off and oftentimes they're worse
off the poor are not really to be
emulated but you want to help them pull
themselves out of their situation by
hard work by the cultivation of virtue
by the improvement of their minds
you know she stresses self-improvement
industry education and independence and
these are all sort of typical rising
bourgeois values the 18th century and a
good part of the 19th century are really
the time in which that social class is
the most dynamic is the are the ones
that are leading the culture so she is
right at the center of that it's
probably important to talk a little bit
about was when we're looking at this
history about the history after she dies
she dies in in 1797 she's only 43 years
old when she dies and her work is is
quite successful the you know especially
the vindication of the rights of women
for the first you know say 30 40 50
years it's translated into French that
it's released in American editions she
influences a lot of women writers
there's quite a few men who are reading
her as well
you know she's she's writing stuff
that's that's in the first caliber when
it comes to social theory and ethics and
then because William guy
when publishes his memoirs about her
it's going to erode her reputation in
part because this is something that I
didn't mention in the biography section
she did live an unconventional life in
many other respects she had a child out
of wedlock
she was the product of a love affair
with this American adventurer who kind
of throws her over there's actually love
letters that she wrote to him that are
they're extremely interesting and are
sort of exemplifying some of the things
that she's talking about in this work
when it comes to love passion marriage
desire virtue all these these sorts of
things that fit in she also had some
some rather unconventional affairs with
other people she had a few suicide
attempts and so all of these sorts of
things when they came out they you know
they're coming out in a time when
reputation and sort of being a you know
that the right kind of person was it was
considered very important for authors
and so a lot of people will then say
well we're not gonna read this stuff
because she's clearly no good was too
bad because they deprived themselves of
a great experience of reading a
wonderful classic work that that will
probably be read you know thousands of
years from now later on as feminism
becomes a real going concern in the 20th
century there is a revival of attention
to her work and people start to
understand the real importance of it and
she's now today considered one of the
most for the most important early
feminists
in some respects I think that that's a
bit too narrow because the what she's
advocating is not just virtue for women
or equality for women she's actually
making an argument a very interesting
argument about the need for both women
and men to cultivate the same kind of
virtue so that they can actually have a
relationship which is one of equality
that provides us with a good lead-in for
talking about what some of the key
themes are so you know we just mentioned
equality so you know equality versus
inequality this is one of the key themes
that she's trying to work out there
she's thinking not only about the
existence of both of those
but what creates them and what
perpetuates them particularly in
relation to women and how they are
maintained in a position of inequality
even in societies that seem to be moving
towards more and more equality she also
talks quite a bit about the nature of
civilization and in her view were not
yet fully civilized we won't be entirely
civilized civilization will be held back
until until both men and women developed
their intellectual faculties develop
their virtues and exist in a station of
equality with each other in which they
can actually have mutual respect and
relationships that are not exploitative
until we have that she thinks that we're
always going to be in a state of semi
barbarism we may think that we're
civilized but we're actually still
living out a kind of you know primitive
lifestyle that has managed to bring
itself forward you know from century to
century to century and consolidate
itself in distinctions of class
distinctions power distinctions wealth
all these sorts of things another key
theme that you're gonna see her talk
about an awful lot is this notion of
virtue so a virtue is a good character
trait and she thinks that these are what
actually human nature is supposed to be
about that we are we're only realizing
our human nature when we cultivate the
the virtues to virtues that she talks
about in particular that I think I
should single out here
our virtues that are often talked about
as feminine or women leave virtues and
she wants to say that if we understand
them in their proper sense they're there
for both men and women and whatever is
just for women in them isn't really a
virtue so she talks about gentleness and
she talks about modesty another key
theme that she's she's coming back to
over and over again is intellectual
development we we have the capacity as
human beings to develop our intellect to
develop our imagination to use our
Faculty of reason and to eventually
expand our mind to make it better and
better and better often times we don't
do that she believes and unfortunately
the kind of education that women are
getting tends to do it less than for men
this is a good point to talk about
another key theme which is education
Wollstonecraft's thinks that education
takes place outside of the schoolroom in
society in our culture in the family in
the workplace and our professions in the
ways in which our ideas are associated
the ways we live on our lifestyle the
lessons and conclusions that we draw
from them that's all education and
education can be done well or it can be
done very poorly
she thinks that most women are actually
miss educated in the society that she's
writing to another key idea is that of
Independence an education is supposed to
make us independent and independence is
one of the key components in a full
human life as a matter of fact she
thinks that we can't entirely cultivate
the virtues unless we do so from a
position where we get to decide for
ourselves where we're not just subject
to another person and so you know the
opposite of Independence would be
dependency and she's very much concerned
with the ways in which women
are kept in conditions of dependency the
ways in which they're educated towards
dependency another key idea that she
talks about that's related to this is
the emphasis on on beauty and pleasing
men as what is most important for women
so in place of you know real virtues in
place of intellectual development women
are steered towards what she calls
bodily accomplishments which are often
detrimental to their health detrimental
to their development as as human beings
and which don't actually get them what
they would want from their their mates
or spouses anyway which is respect and a
genuine kind of love she also does talk
and this is another key theme about how
we want to understand the passion of
love and by that she means you know
everything from straight-up sexual
desire to our you know sort of romantic
infatuation feelings and everything in
between
she tends to downplay this she thinks
that it's not that important in
relationships and that leads us to our
last key theme of this which is that she
thinks that the proper relationship
between men and women if women aren't
just going to be independent is in a
marriage that is based on mutual respect
for the other person as an intellectual
equal
as somebody who's displaying virtue that
you can share in and which develops into
a kind of intimacy and friendship so
those are the key themes things that you
should like keep a particular eye out
for as you go through this this great
work